he
said three things to me about the end
one of which is i don't know how much
longer i'm going to be doing what i'm
doing
i'm going and this sounds what is the
context of this like are you guys
this is out of nothing you guys are
hanging out eating dinner where you're
you're traveling walking i think we were
walking somewhere he said i don't know
how much longer i'm going to be doing
what i'm doing i'm going
first of all i don't like this second of
all
i don't know what it really means third
of all
i'll do what mike does who and mike's
not very smart
you just shove it under the carpet let's
forget it i just blow it off
then he says i don't know how much
longer i'm going to be needing clothes
i'm going what are we talking about here
what's going on
the third thing i forgot what it is i
forgot five or ten years ago what it was
he knew the end was coming okay
and he was saying it to me
um and he was
here in saint pete for maybe four days
just before he died really yeah yeah
just before
two weeks before he died or weeks before
he died let's say
he had played the high life front on in
miami we went there
we brought him back he stayed at this
this place i'm telling you the blue room
which was a motel that they've just
recently
torn down on 34th street but my point is
is that
he
knew what was coming and even though
he's trying to say it to me i'm
not listening to anything he says and
he's very human it's a very human person
whatever that means he's staying in this
hotel he's getting up at four o'clock
in the afternoon that's oh afternoon
that's the wake up time
okay so getting up at four o'clock and
we're going to eat right next to this
place called the blue room
in those days was
a place
where you just line up to get the food
um
what do you call it susan morrison's
cafeteria
so proper people in saint petersburg
this is 1970
1969 um probably 1970.
so you go out and this a proper place to
go
with the family with your wife
morrison's cafeteria and you line up and
you say i want that i want that you're
pointing to it
and the people that got the spoons and
they put it on your plate to put it on
your plate
and now jimmy's first in line i'm second
tony's there and
i think elena
the people that are spooning the fur
food say to me
with their mouths but not their voices
is that jimi hendrix
you know they're pointing is that jimi
hendrix like this is jimi hendrix
he's in morrison's cafeteria at five
o'clock
like what the hell are you even talking
how could this is
impossible i mean he's very famous at
this point
um so all i'm saying to you is that
we go to mars since we you know or if
you go to any club
anywhere with him they always invite him
to play he'll always play always
always you know he may say i need this
kind of guitar or turn the amp
amp around i want it to be louder you
know you don't know what he'll say but
he's looking to play this is where he's
living in his head
in his heart or jimmy myself
tony and a few other people are watching
a movie
on television and it's a movie about
wolves that raise a baby
okay it's an old old movie and
we're watching it and the wolves are
raising the baby doing this whatever
they're doing
there might be foxes i don't even know
and so we're watching it just properly
and we see
we glance over to jimmy jimmy's playing
an
air guitar in his head he's playing
along
with the music in this thing
in this movie this is where his head is
at he's playing
you know then he realizes we see what
his he's doing
you know and he then he starts tuning
his elbow you know i mean he makes it
into a joke
but all i'm saying to you is that all of
these
people musician types
macho man same thing these people are
totally taken up with whatever game
they're playing
it's a hundred percent of their being
hundred
what was it like well first of all what
was it like when you found out jimmy
first passed away with where were you
and
and how i was sleeping they came and
woke me up and they said
jimmy's dead so i'm
new at this game i'm going what are you
talking about he was just here i mean he
was here
like four days we had picked him up
miami brought him back
took him here took him there meaning i'm
not getting it
i'm saying what do you mean he was just
here
you know what are you telling me jimmy's
dead i couldn't get it
um and then they said he's in england he
died he overdosed or whatever they think
it was or you know he's dead
then i had to try to absorb this
but i had lost
my birth mother at maybe
four so i
was forced into learning a people die
people in your family can die this is
how life goes
deal with a dude and
from there to this day i have maybe five
mothers
meaning in my mind i think they're
mothers to me
you know my father married
after my first mother died a lady from
canada
beautiful raised me and all that stuff
in my heart she's my mother but
we had a beautiful phenomenal maid is
what they called him in those days named
arlene
black lady from brooklyn brooklyn
dodgers fan
you know so i could only love the
dodgers i love darlene
this is my mother meaning she took care
of me i'm a little kid
and the story you know i love arlene
it's nothing to even say here
words don't do it and
the beauty of that is that you're
learning
how life goes but you're getting what's
meant for you
this is a lesson you got to learn in
life people can die
you can love anybody if you want to
love them special we're going to tell
them or they're going to play the part
of being your mother
and then you get triple love or
quadruple love you know whatever the
thing is
i mean there's a lady that i know to
this day
that lives in texas that's my mother
she's younger than me you're going
michael what the hell is wrong with you
somebody says this is your mother they
said it to me you know maybe 40 years
ago
i treated her that way she's married to
a
a
friend of mine you know but in my mind
she's my mother if she tells me drink
echinacea tea then i'm going oh i got to
drink echinacea tea because my mother
told me to
you know this is i'm just telling you
this is how the mind works this is a
wild
[Laughter]
thing